les riverains des berges de briand à
traînel sont excédés cela fait des
années qu'ils interpellent toutes les
instances pour débarrasser la rivière
madame de la végétation et des déchets
responsable de débordements lors
d'épisodes pluvieux la des halles la
mairie de fort-de-france et la police de
l'eau ils sont tous au courant du
problème d'insécurité générés par cette
rivière n'ont cure est régulièrement
rien n'est fait tous les courriers que
j'ai date de janvier de février donc je
me prend suffisamment tôt pour pouvoir
planifier pour prévenir cette période
mais il ya en effet quand vous regardez
l'état de la rivière
voyez bien que ça ne date pas de janvier
2020 ça on va pas me dire que c'est le
confinement c'est maintenant je suis
désolé salade de plusieurs années à la
mairie on nous assure que cette rivière
est entretenu chaque année mensonge nous
disent les riverains la mairie elle-même
leur a dit qu'elle n'avait pas les
moyens techniques pour entreprendre un
curage conséquent en revanche des
travaux de canalisations sont entrepris
depuis plusieurs mois à l'embouchure et
cette canalisation devrait s'étendre
jusqu'aux berges des deux brillants avec
les consultants les procédures de
marchés
on était un petit peu retardé mais là
d'ici la semaine prochaine nous avons
des interventions qui sont prévues par
les services de la ville sur un
nettoyage du gain et puis ce fut au tour
ensuite sur la
mise en ondes en valeur des berges la
recommandation que nous donnons aux gens
c'est que de respecter les règles les
mesures de sécurité parce que lorsqu'on
annonce de plus comme c'est le cas
actuellement
il y est il y a bien entendu une
interdiction de traverser le gué
notamment à pied l'autre problème commun
à presque tous les riverains de traînel
c'est l'absence de titre de propriété
dans les années 60 ils ont construit
avec l'autorisation d'aimé césaire
ancien maire de la ville sauf que
certaines maisons sont bâties dans la
rivière pour entamer les travaux de
sécurisation de la zone
la mairie devra les détruire les
négociations avec les riverains
s'annonce donc très animé